the countdown is officially on it is
apple season now in previous years we've
all gathered together in cupertino at
the steve jobs theater for the iphone
ipad apple watch and the new ios release
and at this point
all of those things would have already
been announced but this year
much like pretty much everything this
year that has been completely
thrown out the window so wwdc was
virtual so this is going to be very
similar to that now most likely the
rumors are suggesting that this time
flies event will only cover the new
apple watch
ipad and maybe air tags maybe home pods
or maybe some new airpods studio but
we're not really sure
but there's a really good chance that
the iphone 12 event is getting its
own at the end of the month since the
supply and demand of resources has been
pushed
so significantly due to covid this is
now potentially pushing the release of
the iphone date to a later time in
october so this does make sense to get
everybody all hyped up about the new
apple watch and all of the goodies
and then save the best for last i
wouldn't say the best for last because i
love my apple watch
so much anyway these are all rumors
things that i've kind of pulled from the
internet i will put all of the links to
all of my sources in the description
below i don't have any other
crazy information that you guys can't
just search for yourself
but i'm kind of taking it all and
recapping it all here in one video for
you
i also plan on doing a live reaction
recap after the event
and also a very special edition of our
new podcast we just started our youtube
channel this weekend so if you guys want
to go check that out youtube.com
samebrain i will be posting a special
apple event podcast there
shortly after probably a little bit
longer after because we have to edit it
so just be patient
so the apple watch i would say is
probably one of my favorite tech devices
almost of all time of course other than
the iphone but this
has helped me so much over the past few
years really quantify
my health now the leaks say that there
has been some code found within
ios 14 that can suggest that the apple
watch is finally adding
blood oxygen detection i actually use
this o2 ring sensor
and i test mine at least once a day to
make sure that i'm least in the 96 to 99
range now with the integration of the
sleep tracking into the new watch os i
also think that this will have some sort
of improved detection for that as well
so many of these leaks have been coming
from code that they are pulling
out of the various watch os and ios 14
like this there's a possible new kid
mode for kids
now this could go hand in hand with this
other rumor of a new cheaper apple watch
se
possibly made of plastic and lacking
some of the features like ecg
and blood 02 to cut costs i think this
really does make sense because
obviously if you are going to want to
try to make a cheaper version of the
apple watch you're going to have to use
more inexpensive materials and not have
all of the same features
as the apple watch i wonder if they're
going to call the apple watch pro or
like the apple watch
mini or the apple watch sc that's kind
of what the internet is saying that they
think they're gonna call it also looks
like they might be removing the force
touch
on the apple watch as well but they do
plan on keeping the general design
sort of the same which i'm actually very
glad about because i have so many apple
watch bands that if they do change the
design too much
we won't be able to use any of our old
bands they do always add some new
finishes
or some kind of visual cue on the newest
apple watches to let people know
hey this is the newest apple watch i
just want to let you all know it's
subtle but
it's not as subtle enough that you're
not gonna be able to see it and know
that this is new next up is the ipad it
looks like there's gonna be an ipad 8
and an ipad air 4.
now we did just get an update to the
ipad pro like a few months ago with
lidar and
spec boost so unless they plan on
releasing another ipad pro i feel like
that's not very realistic
these ipad air 4 rumors are based on a
pamphlet that was leaked
a few months ago or like last month or
something now this looks like what is
usually included inside of the box but
it shows a more ipad pro
looking ipad air with the possibility of
touch id built into the side button with
usb-c i love the ipad air but i also
really love my ipad pro so kind of
taking that form factor over the ipad
air making it look a little bit more
like the pro and adding a fingerprint
sensor
is just i'm i'm here for it the ipad air
has always been a very popular choice
for its size and its cost but it really
desperately has needed an update as for
the ipad 8 i would probably imagine it's
gonna get an updated camera maybe dual
cameras
probably no lidar but maybe also touch
id i mean if the air is getting that i
feel like that's probably something that
the ipad 8 should have as well
i mean i don't really know this is just
something that seems logical
i haven't really seen any info that
suggests that they'll be doing an update
to the homepod but i do have my fingers
crossed because i love my homepod
i think if they did some sort of homepod
mini or really just freaking updated
series so that she would work
would also suffice i mean like she works
but then like
she doesn't i mean the homepod has been
out for a couple of years i feel like
there's been some rumors
of potential discontinuation of the
homepod i mean like it'll still work but
i just don't know if there'll be an
update which i hope there is because i
love my homepod so much
i really do have them in every room so
really no matter where i go in my house
i'm never alone air tags could finally
be making their appearance this week
these are the long rumored tracker tags
that they have supposedly been working
on
i used to always use towel trackers for
all of my things
but now the only thing that i'm losing
is my sanity
because i don't ever leave the house so
if we can get an error tag for that
that'd be great so that's what we
potentially have to look forward to
in addition to maybe another event later
this month
i mean i don't know who knows does
anybody know i don't know i'm sure
people that apple know
maybe apple will be like xbox and see
that everyone has already leaked a bunch
of stuff and just troll themselves on
twitter
like xbox did and just give us all of
the actual info to dispel
all of the tornadoes of rumors speaking
of which let's go through those really
quick before i let you click off to
another video
so the 2020 iphone 12 lineup is
supposedly giving us
four new phones an all-new design a 5.4
6.7 and 6.1
inch sizes triple lens 3d camera all ola
displays
5g and an a14 chip here's the rumored
specs from apple insider
and here's what they might look like
iphone 12 iphone 12 max iphone 12 pro an
iphone 12
pro max i absolutely love
this purple mock-up like this is
beautiful it kind of looks like a
brighter version
of the iphone 11 last year it looks like
it's going to be more of a flat
stainless steel
edge design instead of the curved which
i really like and there's this all-new
potential midnight blue color which is
kind of
a very nice contrast well not really
contrast but it's a very similar
shade of the midnight green from last
year i actually think that i like the
midnight blue
a little bit more so i will be doing a
full iphone 12 rumor video very soon
unless everything is announced at the
apple event and i will just then recap
it for you so until then i will see you
guys back here on my channel
for all of the things okay bye
see ya time sure flies when you're in
quarantine
[Music]
time flies
when you're having fun